Paris is in lockdown tonight after a series of bombings and gun attacks that killed more than 100 people at six separate scenes. We're learning more at this hour about a mass shooting in San Bernardino, California, about an hour east of Los Angeles. We have two suspects, both dressed in black. It is clear that the two of them had gone down the dark path of radicalization, embracing a perverted interpretation of Islam that calls for war against America and the West. It's stockpiled assault weapons, ammunition, and pipe bombs.
巴黎今晚处于戒严状态，此前发生了一系列炸弹袭击和枪击事件，在六个不同的地点造成100多人死亡。在这个时刻，我们正在了解更多关于加利福尼亚州圣贝纳迪诺发生的大规模枪击事件的信息，该地位于洛杉矶以东大约一小时车程的地方。我们有两个嫌疑人，都穿着黑衣服。很明显，他们两人都走上了激进化的黑暗道路，接受了对伊斯兰教的歪曲解释，这种解释号召对美国和西方发动战争。它囤积了突击步枪、弹药和管状炸弹。
So this was an act of terrorism designed to kill innocent people. Every time there's a terrorist attack, we ask ourselves, what motivates people to do this? The attacks seem barbaric, nihilistic. But is it that simple? Is that what's really going on? On this week's podcast, we explore the psychology of international terrorist organizations
所以这是一起旨在杀死无辜平民的恐怖主义行为。每当发生恐怖袭击时，我们都会问自己，是什么驱使人们做出这种事？这些袭击看起来野蛮、虚无。但事情真的那么简单吗？这真的是怎么回事呢？在本周的播客中，我们将探讨国际恐怖组织的心理学
and why so many young people join them. Battlefield experiments, conducted with fighters for ISIS and al-Qaeda reveal patterns in the mental makeup of terrorists. We'll use the lens of anthropologist Scott Atron to explore the strange hold these organizations have on young minds. Once you lock into these values, they're immune to social pressures. They're not norms. That is, even if you your best friends, your family,
以及为什么那么多年轻人加入他们。与“伊斯国”（ISIS）和“基地”组织武装分子一同进行的战场实验揭示了恐怖分子心理构成中的模式。我们将通过人类学家斯科特·阿特兰（Scott Atrin）的视角，探讨这些组织对年轻人的大脑所施加的奇异控制。一旦你锁定这些价值观，它们就会对社会压力产生免疫力。它们不是规范。也就是说，即使你最好的朋友、你的家人、
your loved ones are against you, you will not see an exit strategy. We'll also examine the phenomenon President Obama calls radicalization. Is it driven by shadowy recruiters? Or by what Israeli psychologist Ariel Morari would describe as pure pressure in university cafeterias. He says, hey, you know, I'm also willing to do it. I would also carry out this, so he's able to take it. And we'll explore the psychology of violence. What happens when brutality is practiced as a form of theater?
你爱的人都反对你，你也看不到退路。我们还将审视奥巴马总统所说的激进化现象。它是被隐秘的招募人员驱动的吗？还是像以色列心理学家阿里尔·莫拉里（Ariel Morari）所描述的那样，是大学食堂里的同辈压力造成的？他说，嘿，你知道，我也愿意这么做。我也能执行这个任务，所以他能够接受它。我们还将探讨暴力的心理学。当残暴被当作一种戏剧形式来实施时，会发生什么？
The spilling of blood, the brutality, accomplishes two things. First of all, it binds people together who are doing it. And the second thing it does is it scares the hell out of enemies and fence-setters. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Regularly on this podcast, we present counterintuitive thinking, researchers with analyses that challenge popular beliefs, well-held views or notions. This episode is no different.
流血和残暴达到了两个目的。首先，它把正在做这件事的人紧密地团结在一起。它起到的第二件事是，把敌人和保持中立的人吓得半死。这里是“隐藏的大脑”（Hidden Brain），我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantan）。我们经常在这档播客中呈现反直觉的思考、研究人员的分析，这些分析挑战了流行信念、根深蒂固的观点或观念。这一集也不例外。
I first came by the work of Scott Atron and Ariel Marari several years ago, I found their research on terrorism counterintuitive. Where something brainwashing is the sole cause of young people being recruited to ISIS and like-minded terror organizations, Atron and Marari suggests that pure networks matter more, much more. In the popular imagination, it is religious extremism that drives terrorists. But these social scientists argue that religion is often a secondary factor. Where many of us might say that terrorists are morally warped or purely evil, Atron and Marari would point to the role of hidden psychological forces.
我最初接触到斯科特·阿特兰和阿里尔·马拉里的工作是在几年前，我发现他们对恐怖主义的研究是反直觉的。如果说洗脑是年轻人被招募加入ISIS和志同道合的恐怖组织的唯一原因，那么阿特兰和马拉里则认为，同辈网络更为重要，重要得多。在公众的想象中，是宗教极端主义驱动了恐怖分子。但这些社会科学家认为，宗教往往是一个次要因素。当我们中的许多人可能会说恐怖分子在道德上是扭曲的或纯粹是邪恶的时，阿特兰和马拉里会指出隐藏的心理力量所起的作用。
I should say the views of these researchers are not universally shared, but especially in the aftermath of the San Bernardino shootings, I felt their views might be useful to here. I got a call from the medical school in Cartoum the other day, where Professor at the medical school said that her best students have just gone on to found a medical unit for the Islamic State. And this was completely unexpected in what should she do about it. What should the school do about it? This is Scott Atrin.
我应该说，这些研究人员的观点并非普遍一致，但特别是在圣贝纳迪诺枪击事件发生之后，我觉得他们的观点在这里可能会有用。前几天我接到喀土穆医学院的电话，医学院的一位教授说，她最好的学生刚刚去为“伊斯兰国”建立了一个医疗队。这完全出乎意料，她该怎么办？学校该怎么办？这是斯科特·阿特兰。
He's an anthropologist who works at the University of Oxford, the University of Michigan, and the French National Center for Scientific Research. He has traveled to the front lines of war zones to cafes in Morocco and housing projects in the Paris suburbs. He has spent many years trying to understand why people are drawn to join groups such as ISIS, which is also known as the Islamic State. As I get a call saying, will you talk to us?
他是一位人类学家，在牛津大学、密歇根大学和法国国家科学研究中心工作。他曾前往战区的前线、摩洛哥的咖啡馆以及巴黎郊区的经济适用房项目。多年来，他一直在试图理解为什么人们会被吸引加入诸如ISIS（也被称为“伊斯兰国”）这样的组织。当我接到电话说，你会和我们谈谈吗？
Our students, we don't understand this. They were our best students, our brightest students. And they went off to establish a medical clinic we found out with the Islamic State, their parents are hysterical, we don't know what to tell them, can you tell us what's going on? The students were of Sudanese ancestry and most had British passports. They came from well to do families, They had promising careers ahead of them. Families of the medical students were dumb struck. The heartbroken sister of one student spoke to the daily male in Britain.
我们的学生，我们不理解这一点。他们是我们最好的学生，最聪明的学生。我们发现他们去和“伊斯兰国”一起建立一个诊所，他们的父母歇斯底里，我们不知道该对他们说什么，你能告诉我们发生了什么吗？这些学生有苏丹血统，大多数人持有英国护照。他们来自家境优渥的家庭，他们前途无量。医学院学生的家属震惊得说不出话来。一个学生心碎的妹妹对英国的《每日邮报》说。
And we just want her home, we want her safe. Her family love her more than anybody else in this world can. Nobody in this world can love her more than we do. My little sister, she's an A-star student. They're praying on young innocent girls and it's just, it's not right. Atron said he told the teachers of the medical school, the same thing he has been preaching for years
我们只想让她回家，我们希望她安全。她的家人比这个世界上的任何人都要爱她。这个世界上没有人能比我们更爱她。我的小妹妹，她是个全优（A-star）学生。他们正在捕食年轻无辜的女孩，这只是，这不对。阿特兰说，他告诉医学院的老师们，这是他多年来一直在宣讲的同样的事情
to governments and more recently at the United Nations. I said, listen, I can't give you the solution. The solution has to be for you to pay attention, to listen to what they're telling you. I mean, obviously if you had listened to them and engaged with them, you would have had indications of what was happening and you would have been able to talk to them, but like parents,
对政府而言，以及最近在联合国。我说，听着，我给不了你解决方案。解决方案必须是你们去关注，去听听他们在对你们说些什么。我的意思是，很明显，如果你听取了他们的意见并与他们进行了接触，你就会有事情正在发生迹象，你本可以与他们交谈，但就像父母一样，
the older authorities, again, know nothing and again are preaching nonsense things like moderation or this isn't true Islam or whatever baloney they're giving them today. And of course it means nothing. Meaning it is an effective. It's falling on deaf ears. Atron believes these messages won't be effective because they fundamentally misunderstand why the young medical students were drawn to the Islamic state. The authorities painted the recruits as drawn to nihilism. Atron thinks it has more to do with a twisted idealism.
年长的权威们再次一无所知，又在大肆宣扬诸如“中庸”或“这不是真正的伊斯兰教”之类的废话，或者他们今天给他们的任何胡言乱语。当然，这意味着毫无意义。意思是它是无效的。这简直是充耳不闻。阿特兰认为这些信息不会有效，因为它们根本上误解了年轻的医学院学生被吸引到“伊斯兰国”的原因。当局将这些新兵描绘成被虚无主义所吸引。阿特兰认为这与一种扭曲的理想主义更有关系。
The Islamic State Revolution is a revolution. There really isn't much difference I see in the impulse or the impetus to the Islamic State Revolution, then to the French Revolution or to the Bolshevik Revolution or to the National Socialist Revolution. And it appeals to the same sorts of people. Comparing the Islamic State to the French Revolution or the Bolshevik Revolution doesn't mean it will succeed, lots of revolutions fail, but if Actron is right it does mean that it would be a big mistake to underestimate the draw of the Islamic State. In one ISIS video a young British man looks into the camera. He has a status
“伊斯兰国”革命是一场革命。我认为，“伊斯兰国”革命的冲动或动力，与法国革命、布尔什维克革命或国家社会主义革命之间并没有太大区别。它吸引的是同一类人。将“伊斯兰国”与法国革命或布尔什维克革命进行比较并不意味着它会成功，很多革命都失败了，但如果阿特兰是对的，这确实意味着低估“伊斯兰国”的吸引力将是一个巨大的错误。在一个ISIS的视频中，一个年轻的英国男子看着镜头。他身上挂着一个听诊
scope around his neck. He leans in with an earnest expression. All the people in England ask you again. All the Muslims over there, to Allah, leave the land of England and come to make it to here and we'll like to hear and endure to this land and help your brothers and sisters out here. Well, Allah, he there, there is a great cause being fought here and the caravan is leaving. George Orwell in his review of Mein Kampf back in 1939, I'm not crazy about that, Hitlerians, but this was a particularly insightful piece. He said, what is it about Mr. Hitler that appeals?
器。他带着真诚的表情倾身向前。英国的所有人再次请求你们。那边的所有穆斯林，为了真主，离开英国这片土地，来到这里，我们愿意在这里倾听并忍受这片土地，帮助你们这里的兄弟姐妹。真的，真主，他，这里正在为一项伟大的事业而战，大篷车正在离开。乔治·奥威尔在1939年对《我的奋斗》的评论中，我并不是特别迷恋那些希特勒主义者，但这是一篇特别有见地的文章。他说，希特勒先生身上吸引人的地方是什么？
What is the essence of the problem? Look at our societies, capitalist societies, offer their people, ease, avoidance of risk and pain, security, and short the good life. And what is the result? Well, the Oxford Student Union, the cream of our intellectuals, votes they will never fight again. And Mr. Hitler, what is he offering his people? Glory, adventure, even death and destruction, but most of all transcendence and a feeling of self-sacrifice. So Mr. Hitler has understood the essence of human beings. Human beings need not just short working hours,
问题的本质是什么？看看我们的社会，资本主义社会向人们提供的是：安逸、规避风险与痛苦、安全，简而言之就是美好生活。结果是什么呢？好吧，牛津学生联合会，我们知识分子中的精英，投票表决他们将再也不打仗了。而希特勒先生，他在向他的人民提供什么？荣耀、冒险，甚至是死亡与毁灭，但最重要的是超越感和自我牺牲感。所以希特勒先生理解了人类的本质。人类不仅需要短的工作时间，
and comfort, and security, and avoidance of pain. They need at least intermittently a feeling of transcendence and self-sacrifice. And so 80 million people now fall down at his feet. And in fact, the German soldiers in World War II outfought on any measure the allied soldiers be they Russian or American or Brits. Scott Atron says he sees the same conviction among Islamic state fighters. He was recently talking with Kurdish and Iraqi soldiers, a short distance from the front lines in the battle with ISIS.
还有舒适、安全以及逃避痛苦。他们至少需要间歇性地感受到超越感和自我牺牲。于是8000万人现在拜倒在他的脚下。事实上，二战中的德国士兵在任何衡量标准下都比盟军士兵（无论是俄国人、美国人还是英国人）更能打仗。斯科特·阿特兰说，他在“伊斯兰国”武装分子身上看到了同样的信念。不久前，他正在与库尔德和伊拉克士兵交谈，地点距离与ISIS作战的前线不远。
The Islamic state came in June of 2014 in about 80 trucks of four to five people at truck, about 350 people, to free a prison by the way of prison. Because freeing prisoners gains your recruits, they also massacred 600 Shia in that prison. But the Iraqi army trained by the United States, armed by the United States to the tune of billions of dollars, simply ran away. Now, there was one unit on the Mahmur Front in a place called Karamidi, where we had a few Iraqi soldiers embedded with the Peshmerga, and the reason they stayed was because their families actually lived in villages close by. And I asked them, why is it that your fellow soldiers And I ask them, why is it that your fellow soldiers simply ran away or melted into the city? And one said to me, they simply didn't want their heads cut off.
“伊斯兰国”于2014年6月到来，大约有80辆卡车，每辆卡车有四到五个人，大约350人，顺便说一句，是为了解放一座监狱。因为解放监狱能为你赢得新兵，他们还在那座监狱里屠杀了600名什叶派穆斯林。但是由美国训练、美国武装了数十亿美元的伊拉克军队却直接逃跑了。现在，在被称为卡拉米迪（Karamidi）的马姆穆尔（Mahmur）前线上有一个单位，我们在那里有一些伊拉克士兵嵌入到佩什梅格（Peshmerga）部队中，他们留下来的原因其实是因为他们的家人住在附近的村庄里。我问他们，为什么你的战友们
When we hear reports of beheadings or prisoners being set on fire, the Islamic states seemingly in discriminant violence shock us. But the shock can keep us from seeing that such theatrical displays of brutality actually serve psychological goals. The spilling of blood, the brutality, accomplishes two things, and usually has done that throughout human history and across cultures. First of all, it binds people together who are doing it, and the second thing it does
或者我问他们，为什么你的战友们直接逃跑或融入了城市？其中一个人对我说，他们只是不想被砍头。当我们听到斩首或囚犯被放火焚烧的报道时，“伊斯兰国”看似不分青红皂白的暴力让我们感到震惊。但这种震惊可能会让我们忽视这样一个事实，即这种对残暴的戏剧性展示实际上服务于心理目标。流血和残暴达到了两个目标，并且在整个人类历史和跨文化中通常都是这样做的。首先，它把正在做这件事的人紧密地结合在一起，第二件做的事是
is it scares the hell out of enemies and fence centers. Coming up, we'll hear about a parent of a British medical student who left a promising career to join the Islamic State. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. When British engineer Ahmad Mutana realized his medical student son had left the family home in Cardiff in the United Kingdom to join the Islamic State, he was enraged. Police came to his home and showed him a video of his son, Nasir, trying to recruit others to join ISIS.
它把敌人和保持中立的人吓得半死。接下来，我们将听到一位英国医学院学生的父母的故事，他抛弃了前途无量的事业去加入了“伊斯兰国”。请继续收听。这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当英国工程师艾哈迈德·穆塔纳（Ahmad Mutana）意识到他学医的儿子已经离开位于英国加的夫的家去加入“伊斯兰国”时，他勃然大怒。警察来到他家，给他看了一段他儿子纳西尔（Nasir）试图招募其他人加入ISIS的视频。
I feel sick and devastated that my son is caught up in this. He told Daily Mail. He was brought up to love and respect my country, which is Britain. I am his father, and naturally I am worried about his safety while he is out there, but I am also worried about the evil messages he is spreading in this video. Muthana said he rid his house of photographs of NASA, saying, it's a Muslim thing, you don't keep the devil in your house. Atron thinks it's understandable that parents would express shock, disbelief, and anger.
我觉得恶心，而且我的儿子卷入其中让我感到毁灭性的打击。他告诉《每日邮报》。他被抚养长大，要热爱和尊重我的国家，也就是英国。我是他的父亲，自然而然地，当他在外面时我很担心他的安全，但我也担心他在这个视频中传播的邪恶信息。穆塔纳说，他从家里清理掉了纳西尔的照片，并说，这是穆斯林的做法，你不会把魔鬼留在家里。阿特兰认为，父母表现出震惊、难以置信和愤怒是可以理解的。
But he thinks a more productive approach is to look at the young people drawn to terrorist groups with a measure of empathy. By empathizing, I mean listening to people, trying to understand where they're coming from, why they believe what they do and act the way they do, without necessarily sympathizing in the sense that you don't have to agree with them. In fact, you may have to fight them, but it's always better to understand where they're coming from, even in order to fight them. Atron says his approach was inspired by the great anthropologist Margaret Mead and the dictum of an ancient Roman playwright. In recent testimony that you provided at the United Nations, you talked about something that you had learned
但他认为，一个更有成效的方法是以某种程度的同理心去看待被恐怖组织吸引的年轻人。通过同理心，我的意思是倾听人们的意见，试着理解他们的出身，为什么他们相信他们所相信的并做出他们那样的行为，而不一定是在认同的意义上，也就是说你不必同意他们的看法。事实上，你可能不得不与他们战斗，但了解他们的出身总是更好的，甚至是了与他们战斗。阿特兰说，他的方法受到了伟大人类学家玛格丽特·米德（Margaret Mead）以及古代罗马剧作家的一句名言的启发。在您最近向联合国提供的证词中，您谈到了您学到的一些东西
from Margaret Mead whom you worked with in New York many years ago. What exactly did Margaret Mead teach you? Well, she taught me that anthropology is basically a response, at least it was then, basically a response to Terence's dictum, nothing human is alien to me. Violent people, members of militant political groups and religious groups are people, just like everyone else. I want to take you back to something you told me a second ago. I just want to go back to this issue
多年前您在纽约与她共事的玛格丽特·米德。玛格丽特·米德究竟教给了您什么？好吧，她教导我，人类学基本上是一种回应，至少当时是这样，基本上是对苔丝（Terence）名言的回应：“凡是人类的，我都不会感到陌生”。施暴者、激进政治团体和宗教团体的成员都是人，和其他所有人一样。我想带你回到你刚才告诉我的一件事上。我只想回到这个问题
of empathizing versus sympathizing, because when I look at the behavior of the Islamic state, and you sort of see this wanton disregard for human life, the deliberate cruelty, the beheadings, the rape, the enslavement of people, it's hard to bring yourself to think about empathizing with people who do this. Yes it is and that's why being an anthropologist often requires a special commitment to that sort of empathy. In the conventional narrative of how young people get recruited to groups such as ISIS, shadowy recruiters go and search of vulnerable people.
同理心与认同感（同情）的对比，因为当我看着“伊斯兰国”的行为时，你看到这种对人类生命的肆意践踏、蓄意的残忍、斩首、强奸、对人们的奴役，很难让自己去思考对做这些事的人产生同理心。是的，确实如此，这就是为什么身为人类学家往往需要对那种同理心做出特别的承诺。在关于年轻人如何被招募加入像ISIS这样的组织的传统叙事中，隐秘的招募人员会去寻找脆弱的人。
Atron and psychologist Aria and Marari think this isn't the way it usually happens. In a study he has conducted in Israel among captured prisoners, Marari has interviewed a number of would-be suicide bombers. For various reasons, these recruits didn't carry out their missions, their equipment didn't work, or they were caught before they could carry out an attack. Marari finds religious extremism is rarely a central motivator for these young people. He says most are driven by the political goal of ending the Israeli occupation. Now the political goals of Palestinian recruits fighting the Israeli occupation are different
阿特兰和心理学家阿里亚·马拉里（Aria Marari）认为，事情通常不是这样的。在他于以色列在被捕囚犯中进行的的一项研究中，马拉里采访了多名准自杀式袭击者。出于各种原因，这些新兵没有执行他们的任务，他们的设备坏了，或者他们在发动袭击之前就被抓获了。马拉里发现，宗教极端主义很少是这些年轻人核心的驱动力。他说，大多数人都是出于结束以色列占领的政治目标。现在，与以色列占领作斗争的巴勒斯坦新兵的政治目标是不同的
than the political goals of ISIS recruits. But Marari's research shows there are underlying similarities in the psychological appeal of these groups. As in the case of ISIS, many Palestinian recruits report they are radicalized, not in mosques, but in university cafeterias well just imagine a young Palestinian 16 17 18 20 years old if it's with his friends in the universities cafeteria they are talking about yesterday suicide attack that took place in Jerusalem and everybody saying
与ISIS新兵的政治目标不同。但马拉里的研究表明，这些组织在心理吸引力上存在潜在的相似之处。正如ISIS的情况一样，许多巴勒斯坦新兵报告说，他们被激进化的地点不是在清真寺，而是在大学食堂。好吧，试想一下一个年轻的巴勒斯坦人，16、17、18、20岁，如果他和朋友们在大学食堂里，他们正在谈论昨天在耶路撒冷发生的自杀式袭击，每个人都在说
What the great the guy that did it how brave he was how patriotic a hero and One of the guys there or perhaps more than one is that I'm an important young man Marginal in his own social circle, but he wants to be recognized as somebody. He wants to be appreciated. So he says, hey, you know, I would also carry out this, so he's at a tech. Someone over here is the boast, and word gets back to the commander of a group looking for
太棒了，干这事的那个人多勇敢，多有爱国英雄气概啊，而在那里的一个人或者可能不止一个人说，我是一个重要的年轻人，在自己的社交圈子里被边缘化，但他想被认为是一个人物。他希望被赏识。所以他说，嘿，你知道，我也会执行这个任务，所以他在攻击。这里的某个人是在吹牛，消息传到了正在寻找
recruits. The commander sends for the young man. This 17, 18, 19 years old youngster stands in front of this elder commander, revered, famous, admired commander in the commander, and the commander has seen, I heard that you were willing to carry out a suicide attack. They don't call it suicide, of course. They call it a martyr, I mean, is that true? Now, what would the other, that young guy say? No, I was just bragging. He says oh yes of course and he thinks our wealth perhaps something will happen and they won't have to to carry it out eventually. The single best predictor of whether someone gets involved in a
新兵的组织指挥官那里。指挥官派人去找这个年轻人。这个17、18、19岁的年轻人站在这个老指挥官面前，这是一个备受尊敬、著名、受人爱戴的指挥官，指挥官看到，我听说你愿意执行自杀式袭击。当然，他们不叫自杀。他们称之为烈士，我的意思是，这是真的吗？现在，另一个，那个年轻家伙会怎么说？不，我只是在吹牛。他说哦是的，当然，他认为我们的财富也许会发生某些事，他们最终不必去执行它。一个人是否会卷入
terrorist organization is if their friends and peers are also involved. In the case of the medical students, waves of British Sudanese students have headed out to Syria. Akron told me that ISIS has explicitly laid out a path to gaining younger recruits from around the world. The strategy of the Islamic State is quite simple and very well spelled out. And it is, first of all, take advantage wherever there is chaos in the world.
恐怖组织，单一最佳的预测指标是他们的朋友和同龄人是否也卷入了。就医学院学生而言，一波又一波的英苏学生前往叙利亚。阿特兰告诉我，ISIS已经明确规划了一条从世界各地招募年轻新兵的途径。“伊斯兰国”的策略非常简单，也非常明确。那就是，首先，利用世界上任何有混乱的地方。
Create chaos wherever the enemy allows us to do and how do we do that? Well in places like Europe what we're going to do is attack tourist centers, cafes, theaters, stadiums, why? Because these types of places cannot possibly be defended. There are just too many of them, there are too few security agencies and law enforcement, so it will terrorize the population and cause the states against us to disperse their resources in reckless ways that cannot possibly help them in the end. Second, we will appeal to the youth, the rebelliousness, the idealism, the adventure, the rebelliousness, the idealism, the
只要敌人允许我们这样做，就在哪里制造混乱，我们怎么做呢？在欧洲这样的地方，我们要做的就是袭击旅游中心、咖啡馆、剧院、体育场，为什么？因为这类地方根本无法保防守。数量实在太多了，安全机构和执法力量太少了，所以它会恐吓民众，导致反对我们的国家以鲁莽的方式分散他们的资源，最终根本帮不了他们。第二，我们将吸引年轻人、叛逆心、理想主义、冒险精神，叛逆心、理想主义，
adventure, the search for glory, the desire for change that youth have. While the fools, they say, will preach moderation, wasatia, which is exactly what's been happening. We will offer them something great. And so what the Islamic State does and this explains why many of those people in Europe, young people are coming and from many other countries in the world, including the United States, is we will find out who in our enemy populations have grievances, have frustrated personal aspirations, have a need for something glorious, something that transcends themselves. We will draw that out and we will wed it to the story we have of how the world should change and why.
冒险，对荣耀的追求，年轻人对改变的渴望。而傻瓜们，他们说，会宣扬中庸之道（wasatia），这正是正在发生的事情。我们将为他们提供一些伟大的东西。“伊斯兰国”所做的（这也解释了为什么欧洲的许多人、年轻人正在到来，以及来自世界上许多其他国家的人，包括美国）是，我们将找出我们敌人的人口中，谁有满腹牢骚，谁有受挫的个人抱负，谁有对某种伟大事物的需求，某种超越他们自身的事物。我们将把它引导出来，并把它与我们关于世界应该如何改变以及为什么改变的故事结合起来。
Over and over, Atron says, he finds that foreign recruits to the Islamic State are often marginal members of their own societies, people who feel like outsiders. Again, the Islamic State's message, why they're so good at it, is they take each of these personal stories, which will invest hundreds of hours in, and try to show why my personal frustration, your personal frustration, at this moment in your life. It's not because you couldn't get this job
阿特兰说，一次又一次，他发现“伊斯兰国”的外国新兵往往是他们自己社会中的边缘人物，是那些觉得自己像局外人的人。再次说明，“伊斯兰国”的信息之所以如此高明，是因为他们接受了这些个人故事中的每一个（这些故事将投入数百个小时），并试图说明为什么我个人的挫折、你个人的挫折，在你生命的这个时刻。这不是因为你找不到这份工作
or that you failed in this, your team lost or whatever. The reason that happened, you see, is because of this larger set of factors, of this larger world, a set of forces that have been arrayed against you, of which this is just a trivial part and forget about the trivial parts that affecting your life. Go now and deal with the real causes of the unhappiness. Not only of you, but of people like you around the world, the oppressed. When families of students who join the Islamic State appeal to them to come to their senses, the pleas are often ineffective because the young people have found the cause they think is greater than their parents, greater than their families, greater even than themselves.
或者你在这一项上失败了，你的球队输了，诸如此类。你看到，发生这种事的原因，是因为这套宏大的因素，这个更宏大的世界，一组针对你排布的力量，而这只是其中微不足道的一部分，忘掉那些影响你生活微不足道的部分吧。现在就去处理导致不快乐的真正原因。不仅是你，还有全世界像你一样的人，那些受压迫的人。当加入“伊斯兰国”的学生的家属呼吁他们清醒过来时，这些呼吁往往是无效的，因为这些年轻人已经找到了他们认为比父母更伟大、比家庭更伟大、甚至比他们自己更伟大的事业。
You can see the same behavior among followers and other groups, and not just terrorist organizations, even non-violent groups fighting for social justice. What we find, and this is not just true for the Islamic State, this is true for people who are willing to sacrifice their lives and kill others at the same time across the board. And it's also true for movements that are peaceful, but where the people who are driving these movements are willing to shed their own blood. For example, the civil rights movement or movements like Gandhi's movement in India, they are committed to a set of values which are sacred. That means values which are immune to trade-offs. For example, you would not change your children,
你可以在其他群体的追随者身上看到同样的行径，而不仅仅是恐怖组织，甚至是为社会正义而战的非暴力组织。我们发现，这不仅适用于“伊斯兰国”，这也适用于那些随时准备牺牲自己生命并杀死他人的人，全面来看都是如此。这也适用于那些和平的运动，但推动这些运动的人愿意流下自己的鲜血。例如，民权运动或印度甘地的运动，他们致力于一组神圣的价值观。这意味着那些对权衡免疫的价值观。例如，你不会用你的孩子，
or your religion, probably, or your country for all the money in China. And when you have these kinds of values which you will not trade off, and which are not subject to the standard constraints of material life, things that occurred in the distant past, or in distant places that are sacred are actually more important than things in the here and now. They're also oblivious to quantity. It doesn't matter if I kill one or I attract one or a thousand or no one as long as my intention is good and righteous. And once you lock into these values, they're immune to social pressures.
或者你的宗教，或者你的国家，去换取中国所有的金钱。当你拥有这种不会被权衡、不受物质生活标准限制的价值观时，那些发生在遥远过去或遥远地方的事，如果是神圣的，实际上比此时此地的东西更重要。它们对数量也视而不见。只要我的意图是善良和正义的，我杀一个人还是杀一个、一千个人或没有人，都无关紧要。一旦你锁定了这些价值观，它们就会对社会压力产生免疫力。
They're not norms. That is, even if you're best friends, your family, your loved ones are against you, you will not see an exit strategy. Scott Atron has conducted psychological experiments with captured Islamic state fighters on the battlefield. We were in Kierkuk. So there's a front there, mud walls that extend for a thousand kilometers.
它们不是规范。也就是说，即使你最好的朋友、你的家人、你爱的人都反对你，你也看不到退路。斯科特·阿特兰在战场上对被捕的“伊斯兰国”武装分子进行了心理实验。我们在基尔库克（Kierkuk）。所以那里有一个前线，泥墙绵延一千公里。
And about every kilometer there's a mud turret with about twenty fighters inside. And that's where we were working. And we got a hold of some captured Islamic State fighters. And we ran these experiments. In one set of experiments, Atron evaluated how much a fighter had adopted the identity of the group over all the other identities the person might have. Atron and his colleagues found that when a fighter's identity fuses with the identity of the group, there is a psychological change that occurs.
大约每公里有一个泥制瞭望塔，里面大约有二十名战士。这就是我们工作的地方。我们抓住了一些被俘的“伊斯兰国”武装分子。我们进行了这些实验。在一组实验中，阿特兰评估了一个战士将该集团的身份融入到该人可能拥有的所有其他身份中的程度。阿特兰和他的同事发现，当一个战士的身份与集团的身份融合时，会发生心理上的变化。
We have many identities. We may be American or Indian or Red Sox fans or Yankee fans or lawyers or doctors or whatever we are today or tomorrow, but they have only one identity and they will fight and die not just for that group but for every single individual in that group. And once this happens we also have other measures which show they develop a sense of invincibility and actually perceive themselves, their own bodies, to be much bigger than they actually are, and they perceive the other group to be much weaker.
我们有许多身份。我们可能是美国人、印度人、红袜队球迷、洋基队球迷、律师、医生，无论我们今天是或明天是什么，但他们只有一个身份，他们不仅会为那个集团而战、而死，还会为该集团中的每一个个人而战。一旦发生这种情况，我们还有其他指标表明他们会产生一种无敌感，并实际感知到他们自己，他们自己的身体，比实际要大得多，而他们认为另一个集团要薄弱得多。
This idea has a lot of support elsewhere in the social sciences. In some ways, being part of a group is a way of creating an immortal version of yourself. When you remind people of their mortality, for example, they express stronger support for the groups to which they belong. You may die, but your identity in the group will outlive you. I asked Atron and Marari about how they would apply what they have learned to doing battle with the Islamic State. I think it's very important if you want to fight effectively against a militant Islam
这个想法在社会科学的其他领域得到了很多支持。在某些方面，成为一个群体的一部分是创造一个不朽的自己的方式。例如，当你提醒人们他们的必死性时，他们会表达对所属群体的更强烈支持。你可能会死，但你在群体中的身份会比你活得更久。我问阿特兰和马拉里，他们将如何把学到的知识应用到与“伊斯兰国”的战斗中。我认为，如果你想有效地打击激进的伊斯兰教，这是非常重要的
you have first of all to defeat it physically. Despite what people say about hearts and minds, you know, in the second world war there was a Russian Soviet ambassador in London. His name was Maiski, Ivan Maesky. And once somebody asked Ambassador Maesky, what is a good psychological warfare, talking about cards and minds? What's a good psychological warfare? And Maesky replied, a good psychological warfare
你必须首先在肉体上击败它。尽管人们谈论民心所向，你知道，在二战期间，伦敦有一位俄罗斯苏联大使。他的名叫迈斯基（Maiski），伊万·迈斯基（Ivan Maesky）。有一次，有人问迈斯基大使，什么是好的心理战，谈到民心所向？什么是好的心理战？迈斯基回答说，好的心理战
is facts and figures. Facts being victories and figures being dead Germans. And I think in a bit more moderate sense, this applies also to the current situation. If you want to effectively fight ISIS, first of all, the, ISIS in the territory that has occupied successfully. That's the first thing you have to do, and I don't understand why the West hasn't died yet. Atron says psychological weapons might also be needed to fight ISIS. Preaching the virtues of moderation isn't going to work.
就是事实和数字。事实是胜利，数字是死去的德国人。我认为以一种更温和的意义来说，这也适用于当前的形势。如果你想有效地打击ISIS，首先，在ISIS成功占领的领土上。这是你必须做的第一件事，我搞不懂为什么西方还没这么干。阿特兰说，打击ISIS可能也需要心理武器。宣扬中庸之道的德行是行不通的。
They think things will work out and telling them again and again this is in the true Islam. That alone isn't going to do it. You've got to get into their networks. You've got to befriend them. You've got to get the friends of it's like smoking. It's not showing them pictures of cancerous esophagy that are going to stop people from smoking. It's young people getting other young people to stop smoking. Of course, there can be constraining laws and barriers to smoking, but what will really stop them is if their friends have stopped. Two brothers, Ibrahim and Muhammad Ajid, I thought to be among the British medical students who left Sudan to join the Islamic State in Syria.
他们认为事情会解决的，一遍又一遍地告诉他们这才是真正的伊斯兰教。光靠这一点是行不通的。你必须进入他们的网络。你必须和他们交朋友。你必须让……这就像吸烟一样。阻止人们吸烟的不是向他们展示致癌食道的图片。而是年轻人让其他年轻人戒烟。当然，可以有约束性的法律和禁烟障碍，但真正能阻止他们的，是他们的朋友都戒了。两个兄弟，易卜拉欣（Ibrahim）和穆罕默德·阿吉德（Muhammad Ajid），被认为是离开苏丹加入叙利亚“伊斯兰国”的英国医学院学生之一。
They left right before they were supposed to take their final exams in their last year of medical school. The last post on Muhammad's Facebook page is from December 30th, 2014. Most of his posts are of funny videos, pictures of his brother and friends, and soccer teams. Muhammad has 480 friends, likes cold play, and the fresh prints of Bel Air. Abraham has 546 friends. He likes Manchester United, Beyonce and Eminem, and the TV shows, The Boondocks, and Everybody Hades Chris. News reports show that recruits are not allowed to leave the Islamic State if they dislike
他们在医学院最后一年本该参加期末考试之前就离开了。穆罕默德Facebook主页上的最后一条动态发布于2014年12月30日。他的大多数动态都是搞笑视频、他弟弟和朋友们的照片以及足球队。穆罕默德有480个好友，喜欢酷玩乐队（Coldplay）和《新鲜王子妙事多》（The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air）。易卜拉欣有546个好友。他喜欢曼联、碧昂丝（Beyonce）、埃米纳姆（Eminem），以及电视剧《黑门坎》（The Boondocks）和《人人都恨克里斯》（Everybody Hates Chris）。新闻报道显示，如果新兵不喜欢
what they find when they get to Syria. The disloyal are often executed. The British medical students who left Sudan are in touch with their parents through social media apps. They offer few details of what they are doing except to say they are using their medical training. Sometimes they send texts which short audio messages. To their waiting families, these messages feel
他们到达叙利亚后发现的情况，是不被允许离开“伊斯兰国”的。不忠诚的人通常会被处决。离开苏丹的英国医学院学生通过社交媒体应用程序与父母保持联系。他们很少提供他们正在做什么的细节，只是说他们正在使用他们的医疗培训。有时他们发送带有简短音频信息的文本。对苦苦等待的家属来说，这些信息让人感到
turs and uninformed. They don't sound like the young people they used to be. Their parents say they sound different. Hidden Brain is produced by Karam Agar Kalasin, Max Nestrak, Maggie Pennman, Chris Banderayf, and Jenny Schmidt. Special thanks this week to Walter Ray Watson and Daniel Schuchin. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Twitter, Facebook, and Instagram. You can also listen to my work on your local public radio station. If you liked this episode, consider giving us a review on iTunes or wherever you listen to your podcasts. It'll help others find the show.
唐突且缺乏信息。他们听起来不像以前的年轻人了。他们的父母说他们听起来不同了。“隐藏的大脑”由卡拉姆·阿加尔·卡拉辛（Karam Agar Kalasin）、马克斯·内斯特拉克（Max Nestrak）、玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Pennman）、克里斯·班代夫（Chris Banderayf）和珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）制作。本周特别感谢沃尔特·雷·沃森（Walter Ray Watson）和丹尼尔·舒钦（Daniel Schuchin）。欲了解更多“隐藏的大脑”内容，您可以在推特、脸书和Instagram上关注我们。您也可以在当地的公共广播电台收听我的节目。如果您喜欢这一集，请考虑在iTunes或您收听播客的任何地方给我们写个评价。这会帮助其他人找到这个节目。
I'm Shankar Vedantan and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是美国国家公共电台（NPR）。这一集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。